اليوم سنتعرف على سلطه من نوع خاص بالنسبه
تحديدا للنساء انها سلطه الجاذبيه والجمال
الذي يحمل من السحر ما يجعله قادرا على
التحكم ليس فقط بالمشاعر بل بالحياه ايضا
دراسه صينيه جديده نشرت في مجله محددات
علم النفس تقول ان الجاذبيه الجسديه
للمراه تزيد بشكل كبير قدرتها على
المساومه داخل المنزل الجمال يفرض القوه
هذا ما تفترضه الدراسه التي اراد مؤلفها
تاكيد ارتباط جمال الجسدي للمراه
بالعلاقات الاجتماعيه لاسيما في المنزل
الدراسه اظهرت ان النساء الحاصلات على
درجه جاذبيه اعلى كان لهن دخل اعلى
وعلاقات افضل واحترام اعلى للذات مؤكده ان
الزوجات الجذابات قادرات على اتخاذ قرارات
رئيسيه في المنزل
الجمال
[موسيقى]
في انسان بتلاقيه مو حلوه بالمره بس وجهها
حلو ومنظرها حلو يعني هاي يعني مو ضروري
انها تكون بجمالها جمالها مش الها اصلا
جمالها للناس للغير اما تكون طبيعيه
وحلاوتها هيك حلوه لا ما باثر الجمال اذا
كانت جميله وما الها شخصيه هي او ما الها
مش صاحب قياده بالبيت ما باثر عليها المهم
انها تكون صاحبه قياده صاحبه شخصيه صاحبه
كلمه صاحبه اداره الاداره هي بتاثر عليها
بالبيت بالشخصيه مو جمال شو الجمال يعني
الحيط بيضاء بتقدر الواحد تروح تعمل ميك
اب بتقدر تروح تعمل عمليات تجميل تغير
بشكلها لكن المهم مخها اخلاقها
يعني انسجامها مع جوزها مع اولادها في
البيت الاداره هذا المهم مش المهم الجمال
لا طبعا لانه بالنهايه الجمال بتغير هي
اسلوبها وطريقتها وكيف هي بتمشي اسلوبها
بالبيت هذا هو اللي بيفرق مش الجمال
الجمال بيروح وبيجي وبيتغير
[موسيقى]
طبعا ما باثر على سلطتها بالبيت لانه
الاساس ثقافتها فهمها شخصيتها بالبيت
ادارتها لبيتها مش الجمال في النهايه
الجمال الداخلي مش الخارجي هو المهم لا ما
دخل هلا لانه بالاخر واحد برجع له شخصيته
كيف بيتعامل مع الناس كيف
كلمته مسموعه ولا لا يعني الجمال ما له
دخل هادي شو هاد اشي ما له دخل للسلطه او
لا بس المهم انا برايي انه تنضمي الينا من
البحرين عبر المعتوم استشارية الذاتيه
اهلا بك يا عبير معانا في صباح العربيه من
جديد هل بالفعل جمال المراه يؤثر على
سلطتها في المنزل
اهلا بكم صباح الخير العين تعشق كل جميل
الجمال يعطي المدخل يفتح الباب يفتح
الابواب ولكن لا يبقيك في المكان الجمال
اللي مقصود فيه هنا هو جمال الحضور وجمال
الحضور مش بس ملامح جمال الحضور عباره عن
انسجام داخلي الشخص يكون عنده حضور ناتج
عن القوه داخليه يعني الكلام اللي بيتكلم
الافكار المشاعر كلها منسجمه هذه الانسجام
يظهر جاذبيه لا تقاوم اضافه على جمال
الملامح اوكي طيب عبير
هناك خط فاصل بين ان تكون المراه مسيطره
وبين ان تكون قويه بالمعنى الايجابي ما هو
هذا الخط
القويه انك تعرف تستخدم ادواتك بما ينفعك
وينفع الجميع السلطه انك تثبت موقفك وفقط
ماي واي لكن القوه الحقيقيه والسلطه
الحقيقيه انك انت موجود في من ضمن مجموعه
خصوصا لما نتكلم عن عائله او اسره موجود
من ضمن مجموعه فلما يكون عندي انا باور
معين معزز بجمال الحضور تكون السلطه
ايجابيه لمن انا استخدمها لفائده الجميع
اكثر بشكل ايجابي ان انا اسير العائله في
اتجاه في اتجاه صحيح طيب دراسه تقول كذلك
يا عبير ان النساء المستقلات ماليا او
الموظفات او نساء اثريات يكون لديهن سلطه
اقوى في المنزل من هؤلاء الجميلات او
الجذابات ما رايك بذلك
بالتاكيد لان الاستقلاليه الماديه تعطيك
ثقه انه انا مستقله بذاتي او وجودي في هذا
المنزل او وجودي في هذه العائله هو اختيار
اختيار انا يعني انا اخترت بناء على رغبتي
في ان انا اكون موجوده في هذه الشراكه ليس
اجبارا
غيابي عن هذا المكان او او غياب العائله
عني لا يعني ان انا راح احتاج لهم لكن انا
موجوده اختياريا فطبيعي هذا المشاعر تعطي
الانسان ثقه او تعطي المراه بالذات ثقه
خصوصا في ظل يعني خصوصا في ظل مجتمعات
احنا يعني احنا احنا تبرمجنا على كلمه
تكوني جميله واصمتي او كوني جميله واسكتي
بمعنى ان انت لا تسوين ولا شيء اذا انت
جميله كل شي راح يجي لعندك الفكره هنا غلط
الفكره ان عشان كذا طبعا نشوف وحده جميله
جميله وذكيه وقويه تصير كانها معجزه طب هل
يفضل الرجل المراه الجذابه والمسيطره معا
ان يكتفي بالصفه الاولى
اتوقعي يفضل المراه الذكيه لان الذكيه راح
تعرف شلون تكون جذابه وقويه يعني بشكل
مسيطره
مسيطره بشكل مسيطره بشكل ايجابي يعني كانت
السيطره
فعلا يعني
ممكن ممكن نستبدل مسيطره بمؤثره اوكي
مسيطره مؤثره نعم بس انت مع انه الجاذبيه
هي قوه تمنح للمراه بالتالي تستطيع ان
تميل للسيطره معها
الجاذبيه لا تمنح عزيزي الجاذبيه انت
تربينها في ذاتك شنو الجاذبيه الجاذبيه
كاريزما كاريزما شنو معناه كاريزما يعني
الكاريزما بتخلق مع الانسان يا عنده ما
عنده اياها ما بقدر الواحد ينمي الكاريزما
يقدر ينمل الكاريزما عباره عن توافق تام
بين قدرتك على التقدم للامام
والسكون في ان يعني قدرتك انك تكونين شخص
دافئ وفرندلي وبروتشابل يعني بالامكان
التعامل معه بسهوله في نفس الوقت حدوده
واضحه هذه الكاريزما
على وضع الحدود بشكل فريندلي يعني حضور
قوي وجميل في نفس الوقت واضح الحدود هذه
الكاريزما وان شاء الله المره الجايه كمان
نعمل موضوع الكاريزما شكرا لك عبير معتوق
استشاريه تطوير وتنميه ذاتيه شكرا